hello everyone well the title says it
all really garry kasparov is coming out
of retirement and will be playing in the
st. Louis represent blitz tournament for
a total price of one hundred and fifty
thousand dollars and let's see some of
the players who will be playing we have
Nakamura Cora wanna Erin young Kirk in
Anand upon Miyaichi and for World Cup
for wild cards
David Navarro eloquent William Lanier
Dominguez and Gary Kasparov and although
Gary Kasparov is a wild card in this
tournament I don't think he will be an
outsider I really think all the players
will have an extremely hard game against
him and to prove this theory and Gary
Kasparov played the six-game match
against Shekhar Nakamura last year in
the st. Louis ultimate with challenge
and he won three and a half two and a
half and there is the one game I would
like to show you from this event
Gary Kasparov is a white and Hikaru
Nakamura is black so the game went e4 e5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 and casparo
goes for the Scotch opening d4 he takes
d4 Knight takes d4 and then Bishop to c5
which at e3 Queen to f6 and now c3 all
standard Theory pretty much Knight G to
e7 Bishop to c4 and here Saqqara plays
the 95 and in this position
well this light square bishop usually
goes to e 2 it's pretty useful here as
it pretty much paralyzes this knight on
e5 and also it controls this diagonal
and really looks out for this light
squares but in here Gary decided to play
Bishop to b3 and this is a very
interesting game I think because
especially because it's a scotch opening
and in
the World Championship match between
miss Perriman Karpov in 1990 that was
played in Lyon Gary Kasparov intensively
prepared one specific opening and that
opening is the Scotch so I don't know if
he Caron nudist he probably did but as
you can see Gary can still play with the
best
so Quinta g6 eyeing that GGO pawn white
castle's and now d5
I think another game they played in the
Scotch that Casper also won he cart ride
d6 but here he goes for the very
aggressive d5 and it's a it's a very
aggressive move as it's a it prepares
this Bishop h3 move so because power
plays Bishop to 4 which is very nice as
it stops the bishop a Kshatriya will
simply retrieve the bishop to g3 and
block all threats so Bishop f4 and now
Bishop to g4 attacking the Queen Queen
to c2 Bishop captures and v4c takes on
d4 Knight to c6 and here with Knight to
c6 he's attacking the d4 pawn and Gary
defended Queen to d2 and here he was
expecting something like careful or
maybe I don't know improving some sort
of an improvement but Nakamura places
very shocking move and plays Queen takes
on e4 and Kasparov was really stunned
here and he didn't really know what was
going on because this allows this next
move f3
winning the bishop and I don't know well
maybe this was some sort of crazy car
was preparation for Boyd's game or maybe
he just didn't want to lose any more
time so he played this well either way
Bishop to f3 g take step three and the
Queen takes and d4 because power happily
trace Queen squint 874 and I take some
b4 and here's your curve has
three points for the piece but the
spiral quickly grabs the C seven point
so we have King to d7 which was to g3
and now the position is only two points
for the peace and Nakamura captures this
Bishop so Knight captures on g3 a takes
and b3 and so now we have two points for
the piece and doubled pawns in the B
file so it's a it's a bliss game five
minutes per player and I think Hikaru
who was feeling pretty comfortable in
this position and maybe he thought that
Kasparov is out of his game so maybe he
can do something about this Knight to f5
attacking the bishop Knight to c3 d4 and
here castara really fouls up and this be
isolated to D pawn place rook after d1
pinning the King rook H 2 e d8 I hope
the d3 preparing to the blob came to c6
Knight to e2 going for that D pawn again
rope to d5 rook to d1 rope to the 8th
over protecting it well for now but be
sure to f2 so attacking the pawn one
more time and up king c5 and the pawn
seems to be protected but not for long
rope to c1 check King the b5 rope the
c-4 b69 to g3 nice to h3 h4 working to
s1 King to a six rook to c7 rook to f8 b
4 we have g6 922 night to f5 and here
gainer captures finally Knight takes on
d4 Knight takes 24 rotates on before and
now rook the f5 Hikaru avoid trading the
rook and I was watching this game when
it was alive and
both players were in serious pain
trouble and I remember yessir saying how
it's remarkable how well Chicago is
defending this position while being a
piece down so rope the d3r up there for
rope the b3 is protecting pawn king to
b5 rook takes on a seven rook to e8
group the b7 rope the e6 Brooke take
three trying to exchange rooks the other
group to f6 piling up on the f3 pawn
King to g2 roped before b3 King goes to
c6 attacking the rook rook to e7 f h5 c
three check came back to b5 rook to e7
rope to f5 h 4g v h6 and g5 8 x + g5
check King to h3 look at five rubber 27
King a 6-row d7 rook to f4 rook to e3
defending came to b5 Bishop to g3 we
have roof to d4 rook to e5 e now finally
the spiral managers to exchange one of
the ribs so rook takes rook takes rook
to be for rook goes here and here first
power of gives up this one but now his
at spawn will be going forward came to
c4 and here he goes for it s 4v v f5
came to d5 and he rope cuts off this
game's approach to this pawn so rook the
d7 check he has to go back King 3 for f6
rook to f3 trying to stop the point and
here it was a serious time trouble
although this is a winning position
Kasparov plays pawn to s7 and Nakamura
makes it really easy for in place before
and after King to g2 he pushes even
further
b3 and power plays rook to e7 and well
that's all over the King has to move
for example King to b3 Guerra will
capture the rook can after a move like
me to simply stop in the pond so this is
like I said he played six games against
Carlo and he won with a result of three
and a half to two and a half and it's a
very nice game
although okay this blitz but Gary showed
that you can sacrifice a piece like that
and play against Gary Kasparov the beast
so yeah this event will be played in
August I think from 2nd to 19th of
August and yeah I'm really looking
forward to it and well you know Gary
Gary is always playing for the win
always like Megan is going for that
first place and I think it will be a
great event so yeah this was the game
and thank you all for watching thanks
for your time and I'm interested to hear
your opinion is what do you think how
Gary will do in this tournament in bliss
and the rapid section so yeah see you
soon